hey hey everyone mic check is is
everything okay like with the voice all
right great and thanks Antonia for the
introduction that was about half the
talk so uh we'll we'll focus the rest of
our time into like the nitty-gritty of
the library
so um first of all welcome everyone to
our session on autoglo on autoglo on is
our automl library that provides a
variety of data modalities for you to
work with
uh myself John R and Alexander will be
presenting the session my name is Jenner
I've I work at AWS I'm a senior applied
scientist I've been with the company for
about four years now and in the general
data science space for about a decade uh
Alexander my colleague is also an
applied scientist at AWS and together uh
he got his PhD recently from the
Technical University of Munich and
together we work on the forecasting time
series uh features within the General
Auto go on framework
so
um
let's start
so I'm going to start with uh basically
describing ml in a nutshell and try to
frame the problem of automl there but
like this is ml in a nutshell before
chat CPT basically but like what what
you might encounter in any ml problem or
in the general let's say workflow of a
data scientist is you have data right so
that data can come in multiple
modalities that might be images Text
tabular data and time series data
perhaps and you have a specific task
that you want to address for example if
it's tabular data you might be
interested in regression classification
if it's images could be image
classification
Etc
and finally what you really want on the
third pillar here is you want a machine
that can make predictions like a test
time on data it has never seen before
and hopefully those predictions are
accurate predictions
um they they are basically usable they
they arrive in like good time Etc and in
like that uh second pillar that does not
at all do any justice to the amount of
work that is required is the real work
of like most some of the work of a data
scientist which is pre-processing that
data trying out different models trying
out different approaches for solving
that task and finally
you know selecting one model or one
approach that can give you the best
performance at test time right
and automl in a nutshell is trying to
take that second pillar
and trying to automate as much of that
away as possible so as to make the lives
of data scientists much easier and get
to the most accurate models with like
maybe as little as three lines of code
and in in the least amount of human
involvement as possible Right
and auto gluon does just that auto gluon
is an automl Library framework that it
aims primarily to democratize machine
learning so as to empower the next
millions of data scientists
and it what it does for you is in a
nutshell it builds accurate models for a
variety of tasks in like with image data
Text data time series data or tabular
data with as little as three lines of
code hiding away all of that complexity
that we just talked about in the second
pillar
and it is open source it's available on
GitHub we'll share the links and it is
also very easy to install it's available
on Pi Pi so you can just pip install
auto glue on and get started with auto
glue
Auto glue on is used in over 200 Amazon
projects internally so it is it Powers
bits and pieces of our external facing
AI Services those you might have heard
of include like for example sagemaker if
you've ever used that it also is used
internally by amazon.com teams and a
variety of tasks for example in supply
chain tasks
Etc and not only that it is also adopted
externally by 50 companies at least that
we know of brand names including ones
like Intel Nvidia IBM and autoglo on on
a variety of tasks that it was designed
to work on it is the state of the art in
terms of performance or like performance
per training Time Performance for
inference time and it was featured as
the opening keynote of the automl
conference in 2022.
so I will first start
this talk by describing what it can do
for tabular data and trying to give you
a sense of like uh like how easy it is
to use and what it does under the hood
and then Alexander will take over for
like the more interesting stuff that
includes images text and time series and
time series the one that's really
closest to our hearts
and to be able to do that let me first
start by introducing uh the problem the
problem is well it's the first problem
that you see in data science school like
if you ever went there like on day one
right so it's like you have a table of
data and it includes some columns those
columns are your features and
particularly if you're interested in
supervised learning that that's most of
what we're interested in ought to go on
you have one particular column that is
of interest that column is your label so
to speak and if that label is real
valued you're trying to solve an
aggression problem trying to predict
that column in terms of the others and
if that feature is uh categorical you're
trying to solve a classification problem
and auto gluon we promise that can do
that in like as little as two or three
lines of code
trying to solve that uh
tabular problem would be as easy as just
calling the tabular predictor object and
that's really the only class name that
you have to know about if you're trying
to address tabular problems you give it
the name of the label column that is
once you know you want it to expect from
the data you're going to give it you
point it to the data you tell it vaguely
what to do like focus on quality here
like try to get me the best most
accurate models possible you specify the
time limit we're going to go into the
details later and you
and really it just takes an hour to
train the best it can the best
classification of regression models
depending on the task it can for you and
you can then take that predictor object
you can save it and then like you call
it back and you can use the predict
method on it at test time
so
um
and you know how do we do that how do we
hide away all of the complexity of like
building models selecting models
optimizing models and giving the best
performance and to be able to describe
that I should first really
um
go into a bit of History here
so how these models or how Auto gluon
came to be the the real inspiration of
autoglone is actually
um maybe like if you've ever competed in
machine learning competitions like on
platforms like kaggle
if you did that five years ago maybe it
was easy to call whatever was the
state-of-the-art classification model
for example back then for example your
random Forest random forests were pretty
popular this might be more than five
years ago or like XG boost and you could
have gotten like a really good let's say
ranking and that was like the good old
days of capital but really soon after
that what happened in uh like the
kaggler machine learning competition
space is people started building these
automated pipelines that just generate
like hosts of plethora of features
um train like you know just swaths of
models like different models and then
just build those models on top of one
another stack them on top of each other
into these huge monstrous architectures
and
um get the best for performance this was
actually also the case that in the
Netflix uh competition if anyone
remembers that so in the Netflix
competition Netflix went out and said
like can somebody please point us to a
good algorithm for uh doing
recommendations and the best thing that
came back was like something that the
Netflix Engineers I said okay we accept
that that is performing very well but
like this is a monster like if we went
out and tried to implement this like it
would take us ages
and auto glue on what it tries to do is
it tries to replicate as much of that
competition winning logic
but like in a completely automated
manner in a completely like hiding away
all of the complexity of both training
such architectures and also deploying
them in test time
with as like with just a very simple
very narrow very concise interface for
its users
and uh that philosophy also reflects in
the competition results of course so in
many uh you know competitions where uh
like Auto glue on is tried and just like
with either no or very little tuning it
can come to very competitive rankings uh
and as Alexander will talk about not
only in tabular tasks but also in in
multimodal tasks
and not only that in academic benchmarks
as well this is The automl Benchmark
it's a very comprehensive
um
comparison of different automl
Frameworks so other Frameworks that are
trying to solve this problem of like get
the best model with minimal human
intervention in the best possible time
it categorically outperforms all of the
other Frameworks some of which are
commercially available
it does this not only on like on average
but uh I could say categorically across
different tasks so binary classification
multi-class classification and
regression problems and also for
different time windows so when all of
the Frameworks are given one hour to
train also for when all of the
Frameworks are given four hours to train
Etc
and that the paper is available in
archive and
um like I would recommend it as like
also a good like introductory reading to
the automl space if you're interested in
like an academic view of things
um and to be able to describe uh how
that happens I already alluded to like
competition beating monsters but allow
me to go into a bit more detail at an
intuitive level on how that happens so
if you went to any automl conference
even like last year or mention the word
automl to people working in this space
their uh perception of that concept
would be equivalent almost to this uh
thing called the cash problem there in
parentheses which is like the combined
algorithm selection and Hyper parameter
tuning model
uh problem which basically just says
let's say you're trying to solve
regression you have these very different
models let's say those in scikit-learn
one of them is like linear regression
another one is like support Vector
regression etc etc and what you want to
do is given a specific amount of time
you want to go to each one model you
want to tune their hyper parameters
maybe you uh sort of search the best
regularization hyper parameter in one
you try to search for if you're doing a
neural network regression for example
you try to search for the best neural
network architecture in one and try to
come up with the one single best model
that wins overall that you expect it to
generalize the best at prediction time
autoglo on does that but it also does a
few things on top
so first it has some let's say uh
built-in data pre-processing
data preprocessing that you might find
in some of those like competitive
machine learning pipelines it has
emphasis on Modern deep learning
techniques so
like it always will include some sort of
deep learning even if it's working on
tabular or time series data to get like
squeeze out the best performance for you
from your data and it can like all
completely hide away the complexity of
doing that right so you don't have to
um like even if you have a GPU it will
sort of try and find it find it and use
it for you
it has
um lots and lots of tricks and
optimizations that go into like how to
select models and what type of problems
and like Which models to prefer it has a
lot of presets as we will talk about so
you can sort of maybe not being at all
an expert user you can nudge it in the
direction of like this is the type of
models that I want to use and this is
the type of performance that I want to
get out of this library but most
importantly there is number two and like
I ask myself why we put it there and
number two is uh ensembling why a
multi-layer stacking so it's that idea
of building monsters like with models
upon models upon models instead of
relying on the single best model can we
come up with the best Ensemble of models
that won't really penalizes all that
much at test time in terms of like how
long it takes to predict but it really
gives a huge performance boost in terms
of accuracy and
like the task at hand
and the key idea of assembling may be
going a bit into that is
that simply many are better than few
right so if you have two models and
those two models make their own mistakes
so to speak so they have their own
inductive biases and they look at the
same data set but they fail in different
ways those two models or three models
can come like they can vote within each
other so to speak and come to a
consensus and that consensus uh will uh
usually like all you know in some cases
always be better than uh the uh any one
individual model even if those models
are worse in isolation
and when you're trying to solve this
cash problem you're trying to select the
best algorithm that the thing is that
you have gone and spent all that compute
in trying to find that best model right
so you've you've done your linear
regression in our previous example
you've done your support Vector
regression you've done your neural
network so why throw all of those away
at test time instead of just like taking
some of them and packaging them and
ensembling them into a new model and
that that's really what
uh the key idea of ensembling is and in
multi-layer stack ensembling it's the
the idea is that you uh get your input
data you try to
um not there it appears you you have
trained all of the different models your
linear regressor your support Vector
regressor your your neural network
Etc and uh what you do
on top is you get your original data
think a data frame you concatenate you
you join in the the predictions of the
layer 1 models and you use that new data
to train a new cohort of models however
of course the key trick here to to
enable like better generalization is
that this new data is out of full this
is like a new data set that was held out
from uh training the first let's say
chord like the the first layer of models
and this this is really like all there
is to it this is what at least Auto Glow
on tabular Taps heavily into instead of
like very very involved hyper parameter
optimization algorithms things like
Bayesian optimization
uh let's say multi-fidelity methods
things like that if you've ever heard
that are more like you know classical
let's say autonomo
and of course for all of that to work
you need a good model zoo and auto glue
on offers a good variety so like all of
the things that you can come across at
and kaggle maybe uh we we try to put
them in there and try to maintain the
complexity of making those things play
nice together for you including things
like XC boost like GBM cat pushed neural
network models that are based on pytorch
uh that are all in there and that that
will hopefully come and start working
together when you do the PIP install
and we try to hide away all of the
complexity behind this very intuitive
API where now I can go into more detail
you just tell it what you're trying to
do you and label class essentially does
that you say okay give me a predictor
object this is really one of the few
objects that you need to know about if
you're using the library and you're
trying to predict a column named class
you point it to the data set that data
set might be a string like a file name a
URL can be a pandas data frame can be a
variety of things
and you tell it presets so presets is
um you're trying to nudge the library so
we offer like a bunch of these presets
now you're trying to nudge the library
into selecting
um like a strategy really so best
quality means you want the the most
accurate models no matter what uh but
you could have said like for example
fast inference So you you're trying to
tell it to okay you know maybe sort of I
I have a little bit of give in terms of
uh accuracy but uh please give me
something that will work fast at test
time
and the time limit uh is like how much
you wanted to train here it's like one
hour in terms of seconds you're saying
okay I want you to do whatever you do in
the the time frame of an hour
and that's really all there is to it it
will train a host of different models
that were like we work on all the time
to pre-select like the the roster of
models that will work best for you and
hopefully give you something that works
like state of the art performance
okay now is the time I hand over to Alex
for the rest of the talk thanks a lot
thank you
um thank you chairman
um so as we have seen with the tabular
predictor we can do extremely well in
different tablet prediction problems
like classification regression but of
course in many practical applications
the data that we have does not really
like perfectly fit into this format of
just a table that has numbers and
categories in it very often we have to
work with images or maybe text data or
even like in some quite challenged
applications we have the combinations of
all these data modalities together where
you can have both potentially multiple
images various text fields in addition
to the table data we have seen before
like new numbers and categories to make
this a bit more specific we can have a
look at the Pathfinder computation that
took place in kaggle where the goal was
basically to predict when different when
pets will get adopted so for each pet
you had a picture and so an image also
some tabular metadata described in this
image and the goal was to predict some
score which tells us how quickly this
bet is going to get adopted and this
would help the shelters to better help
pets find their new homes and here you
see we have the combination of all these
different data types in a prediction
problem
um as a like a bit more of a you know
like practical minded example we can
think of some online store where you
have a huge catalog of products and
there each product also has all of these
different features we have multiple
photos of the product we have a text
field which is a description and the
title and also have different numerical
and categorical attributes like price uh
color maybe model Etc and one question
you might be interested in asking is
whether this product is actually a
duplicate of something else we have in
the data set so let's say when a new
seller comes to the platform tries to
sell a new product
um you want to say is this what is what
they're trying to sell something we
already have in our catalog or is it
um something new that we should like
list as a new item in the category and
of course these are just some examples
I'm sure in applications that you're
working on you have encountered some
other problems where you have to deal
with this multimodal data where all the
different data modalities are present
and argon can also help to solve
problems like this and again to work
with this data we again have to somehow
coerce it into a table of format but now
the stable you see is a bit more General
than what we have that what China has
showed us before where now we also
besides the numerical and categorical
data types we also have some other data
types like images and text for example
for images we can have paths to images
area that you're stored on your computer
and for text it's just strings that we
have there for some other applications
like if you have to do object detection
you want to find different objects and
images you can also have bounding boxes
as a column here in the data frame or if
you want to do name an entity
recognition text you can have this named
entities also there's another attribute
and once you can convert the data into
this format you can again throw it into
outer glow on and get the best possible
prediction in a limited amount of time
and for this um there is a multi-model
module of outer glowing where we have
another object called multimodal
predictor which takes care of various
tasks associated with such multimodal
data like images text
Etc
and as you see the API here is very
similar to the table predictor just a
few lines of code fit in predicting and
this solves the problem and and under
the hood what happens here is we wrap
various Foundation models coming from
libraries like Tim mm detection clip hug
and face Transformers and combine their
predictions so we do multi-modal Fusion
of these various models we train special
test specific hats that allow us to
fine-tune this model specifically to
your task so say even if you don't have
much experience working with such
complex models yourself you can just
put your data in this format throw the
multimodal predictor edit and it will
take care of all these complex
fine-tuning jobs
for you
we can also use these models mentioned
in here in a different way and combine
them with the tabular predictor and so
let's say if you have some
classification problem where you have to
classify some images one thing you can
do is you can use these Foundation
models to get embeddance which is
basically converting each image into
some array with something dimensionality
and then with this these embeddings that
we have obtained from the models we can
again put them into Auto Glow and
tabular and train the tabular and Sample
we have seen before so essentially what
this does it converts the multimodal
problem into a tableau problem where we
can use all the classical tools for
Tableau Data and then just uses the
tablet predictor to solve the problems
that you have
um in terms of support for various
problem times that we have for
multimodal data these are as I already
mentioned the classical things like
classification and regression but now
for combinations of images stacks and
tabular data
and but also some more interesting
things that are more specific to
um this multimodal data so one such
example is named entity recognition
where let's say you have various
documents with text and you might be
interested in finding some enter this
mentioned in there let's say there is
some company name you want to see
whether this company name is mentioned
in various text documents and this way
multiple predicted with the problem type
and ER for name entity recognition can
do this for you and we can also do
problems that are like more image
specific such as object detection and
where you want to find various objects
located in an image so let's say for
like self-driving you might want to be
able to you might want to detect
pedestrians you might want to protect
detect other cars or stop signs or
things like that and this is covered by
the object detection problem type and
finally what I mentioned as an example
in the beginning with this like object
matching and this is what we call here
as multimodal matching and there the
question is where you have different
objects represented by images text
tabular Data you want to answer the the
question are these two objects the same
so given a bunch of images text
descriptions and table data for one
object and for the other we want to ask
is this the same object or is it
something else
um or other different so this way the
multimodal prediction will just give you
some score that tells you how similar
the two stains are
um
um in terms of their specifics as to how
this whole thing works and like I said
we use various Foundation models
provided by these libraries and
depending on the type of the data so
depending on the modality whether it's
images text or just tabular data we pass
it to the respective models they can
process this data and these models are
some things like I don't know efficient
net or resnet if you know like for a
computer vision applications Transformer
models
um or even multimodal models that takes
multiple inputs such as clip and then
once um for the multimodal projector
once we pass them into these models we
can then do fine tuning so depending on
the application let's say if you want to
do classification it passes data into
the models and then trains an additional
layer on top which helps you classify
based on the inputs coming from these
models
so essentially taking care of all this
complexity of managing various models
coming from different libraries with the
simple API of the multi-model predictor
um
the final thing that I want to talk
about today is a
um is another application supported by
other glowing which is time series
forecasting and this is again quite
different from table of data quite
different from multimodal and Aragon can
help you deal with this as well
and so time series is essentially some
set of measurements to make at regular
intervals let's say you're some Energy
company and you want to
um you want to you can measure like the
energy consumption of some household
every hour
and you can plot it like here you just
use this curve so for every hour we have
the measurement and they're usually
interested in asking the question what
will happen in the future how would this
develop over time for an energy company
it might be interesting for example to
Planet capacities for electricity let's
if say if you if you expect a big spike
in consumption you need to make sure
that you have the available capacity in
your network this also doesn't have to
be in electricity consumption can be for
example demand forecasting in a retail
where you have to stock your inventory
to make sure that if there are more
sales coming you have enough
and enough of the units in stock to
fulfill this demand and these all these
different questions of where you have
some quantities changing over time you
can frame them as time series
forecasting problems
um the way we are usually interested in
solving them as practice is but not
we're just giving you a single
prediction for every time step into the
future so I don't want to say like the
energy consumption tomorrow is going to
be 150 because it doesn't that's not all
we need to make these uh like decisions
in the end Downstream what we really
care about is the range of possible
outcomes so maybe we want the model to
tell us okay there is a 90 chance that
the demand for this product tomorrow is
going to be 150 and 170 units and this
way we're actually able to plan our
inventory where we know okay we are kind
of expect to be within these reasonable
Within These bounds and this is what we
use for the downstream predictions and
mathematically this corresponds to
predicting the quantiles
um of the distribution which essentially
means the model just gives you some
number and saying so here we see the
10 quantile the model says there's 10
chance that the maybe demand for this
product is going to be below uh this
number in here and you also predict that
90 quantile sense of there's a 90 chance
the demand is going to be below uh this
number in here and in total this is kind
of the range that we can expect to see
for our time series and and this is
exactly the kind of problem that outer
glow on time series is designed to do is
to generate such probabilistic forecasts
a four time series data
another important aspect um when doing
time series forecasting is that we don't
usually only have that one time series
that we are trying to predict so let's
say we don't only have the sales for one
product that we are trying to predict we
actually have a lot of other additional
information
um for example we can have some other
things that change over time let's say
we know that maybe we know if we'll have
some promotions on different items we
know if there will be some holidays or
weekends and as you can imagine this can
all affect say your sales or
um other properties of the time series
and this can all be combined together to
generate the most accurate forecasts and
so in this figure you see on top there
original times here that we are trying
to predict we have some other time
series that we only know in the past
which can for example be demand for a
related product in a different category
that we have observed historically and
there can also be some other time
Verizon coverage which is maybe like an
indicator whether we have a promotion on
this item or not and that we also
because we control it we also know what
its value going to be in the future
and all of these we can combine together
and describing them as covariates and
finally
um when working with these time series
data sets we usually don't just have a
single time series you want to predict
but we have many time series that we are
trying to predict simultaneously so
let's say for
um demand forecasting we don't just want
to predict the demand for a single
product we want to predict demand for
all the products in our catalog which
can be thousands of Time series each
corresponding to in separate to a
separate product and here for each time
series we can also associate some
metadata like name of the products
category price or maybe some other
features that help us generate the
forecast for example if we know that
some products are all sold in the same
location we might want to give the model
the capability to generate similar
forecasts to the products sold in the
same store that is located in the same
state
um to feed the air we can fit such all
these all these types of data into
um to Outer glow on by combining them
again into a data frame which we now
call A Time series data frame
where the idea is to stack all these
various time series into one big table
where for each role we have some
indicator for the time series so here
you see we have the indicator for
product a and we also have one column
describing the timestamps telling us
when
um telling us when the times UFL was
recorded we have the Target Time series
which is the maybe the demand for the
product that we have at each specific
day and we can also have some additional
covariates in this case we have the
weekend which allows the model to
determine whether
um
um which a lot of the models uses
information in the production as well
and once we pack all of our data into
this time series data frame
um we can just call autoblow on the time
series predictor in this case and it
will generate a probabilistic forecast
for us
as you see the API is also
um quite simple but compared to what we
have seen before we have we just have to
specify the prediction lens down how
many steps into the future we want to
predict so let's say if I have Daily
Time series data this way I will tell
the predictor please generate the
forecast for the next 30 days for each
time series in my data set
and we call fit we call predict as usual
and now predictions will contain the
probabilistic forecasts for all the time
series in my original training data so
you see what's a bit different in Time
series world is that we don't really
have this like training validation split
we'll try and test split we only have
training data and then when we generate
the predictions this contains the future
this contain the future values of the
time series
um that we had in the training set
and internally
um the time series module combines
various the forecasting approaches
starting from simple statistical models
like arima that essentially capture
simple patterns in the data like
seasonality Trends
um maybe some other aggressive structure
and these are usually very fast to fit
but
um might not be super but not be super
accurate so to compensate for that auto
loan also fits deep learning models from
the gluing TF Library such as DPR and
these are usually take a bit longer to
train but can give you more accurate
predictions and also
do quite well when combining these
various and static features we have seen
before
and of course there we can use the
integration with Auto Glow and tabular
to use the different tabular models like
CAD boost and light GBM and in use as
usual in the autoblown way we do a
sampling of all these models to generate
the best possible model that will give
you the most accurate forecast
I want to quickly jump over a few things
here that are not really specific to the
time series model
um but what I want to show you is that
essentially in outer glowing even though
the basic API is very simple where you
only need a few lines of code to Define
your problem and generate predictions
there's also lots of room for
configuration and you can really tailor
it to your specific application and
you can tell to your specific
application and make sure that it
generates the best result for you if you
have something that is very non-standard
and it's not covered by the presets or
the default
so for example for time series you can
say which quantile levels you want to
predict you can say which metric should
be used to measure your forecast so you
can say say with this choice you would
say I care really care about the
uncertainty of my forecasts with some
other choices you could say I only care
about having a single accurate
prediction for each time step which is
like a time and which is
um
which is like a point forecast and also
for when trading the models you can as
usual use the preset in all these
different modules but you can also use
outer go on as like a very simple
wrapper about around other libraries so
let's say if you wanted to train
statistical models deep learning models
tree based models for forecasting
usually you would have to implement the
train validation strategy yourself some
evaluation pipeline various data
pre-processing by hand but this way with
auto blown you can also just say I only
want to train these models and other go
on with automatically train these models
evaluate them for you and
and basically simplify your work as
maybe some more advanced user who
doesn't need the presets but wants to do
something custom themselves
um yeah and since we're closing time so
there are also some other modules
offering other functionality in Aragon
that I haven't covered here which is
more like additional functionality that
you might be interested in using and
yeah and
and finally just to say like if you are
interested in learning more about how to
go on please visit the website we have
lots of information in there we have the
documentation and we have various
tutorials quick start guides
installation instructions and since it's
an open source package you can visit on
GitHub and you can also of course also
of course welcome to contribute uh if
you would like to add some new features
or tell us about something that you
found in the package and you can just
install it with Pip and try it out thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much for this great
presentation so we have quite some
questions
um on slido the first one would be
stakeholders often explicitly ask for
explainability to what extent and how
does autoglone enable that
so I
awesome so we I know we had at one point
some explainability features in the
tabular module it's not like a primary
focus of the library so we're it's more
of a accuracy type of like that's what
we optimized for I guess
um but like one could always uh as
Alexander just talked about like by sort
of focusing the selection of models to
only those that are very interpretable
Etc one could sort of nudge the library
towards
um that direction however
um we do not have like out of the box
support for explainability and for
example in Time series or um multimodal
problems as far as
how would you deploy a model after
training
so this is one of the cases where other
modules of Aragon can be helpful for
example autoglone Cloud allows you to
both train the models in the cloud and
also deploy them in there so you would
just get an endpoint where you can send
your data and get the predictions back
um this is I guess the recommended way
of doing this but you can of course also
because it's open source you can deploy
it on your own infrastructure and we
also offer Docker containers on AWS that
you can use for that or you can you know
since it's an open source Library just
install it yourself and use it in your
own infrastructure
cool what work does autoglone do in the
feature pre-processing processing stage
for example fill the missing values and
such
um this is specific for every model so
this is like one of the ideas of auto
loan is to generate predictions that are
as diverse as possible across different
models to make sure we get the good ones
so in for example for tabular data this
is all model specific so for each model
we try different pre-processing if you
want you can override those defaults uh
but by default we are trying to try out
many different strategies to make sure
we get the right thing in there cool
comparing to Pi carrot as also an automl
platform what is the what are the pros
and cons of this one
um I'm not really familiar with my
character unfortunately uh yeah
um does the time series forecasting also
work for relative days
IG day one day two Etc
um yeah I mean so the generate the
forecast contains predictions from
multiple time steps so if you say you
only
I mean I guess you can just generate the
prediction lens to be let's say if you
have to need to have forecast for up to
10 days you can either use one predictor
and then only look at the forecast for a
single day or you can train multiple
predictors with different prediction
lengths this is the standard way okay
I'll say
uh are the sub models extractable for
further tuning
um yes but since we mostly rely on
samples it might not be like you might
not be only interested in a single
sub-module
um but in principle this can be done yes
cool
I mentioned the focus on deep learning
methods how many samples it
needs for robust solution
and in a seasonality based time series
for example
so I guess based on some benchmarking
that we did ourselves for a Time series
for the smaller time series usually deep
learning models don't give you that much
of an advantage over the simple ones so
I think in that setting if you have
little data you would mostly use the
statistical models for forecasting and
but you know autogome automatically
determine whether like which one should
be used but what I want to mention like
we don't really support cold start
forecasting so if you only know half the
time series for one or two time steps
this is one case where autoglone is not
there yet to support it but this is
something we consider adding in the
future
um how do you tackle back test
overfitting for the time series case
um
I I think that's a really good question
so one thing we do is like we enable
multi-window back testing so like you
can actually that's one of the
configuration parameters that you could
have put into the time series predictor
object the same like uh during fit you
you say like I I actually want you to
not only focus on one window and try to
predict that and model select based on
that do that on multiple windows by
iteratively fitting models going forward
okay
is it possible to do hierarchical
forecasting with auto glue on
not not yet
okay why why don't you use profit for
Time series
so that that's another part of I I think
autoglo on history there was a time that
we did included in the model zoo over
our experience with profit has been that
like the difficulty of maintaining it
especially during inference and
deploying it to like cross-platform it's
just like the
um the difficulty of doing that doesn't
justify the accuracy benefits we get
similar benefits from other statistical
models Fair is it possible to
parameterize a forecasting Horizon for
the feature lack creation feature or
lack creation
um yes so as I mentioned here you can
configure all the models that we have in
the forecasting Zoo so you can provide
those type of parameters and say what is
how exactly you should they should be
configured which lags they should use so
I'd like to to to be clear this is like
a model specific choice right so not all
models are designed to work with
features even so
okay so there are many more questions
actually
um I bet you can approach
um those two and ask the questions
afterwards so again thank you very much
for a great presentation thank you
[Applause]